Let's take a look at our previous code to load an image. Now remember, it was
three lines of code to create an image, set a callback, and then define the
source. The first steps in writing an asset manager would be to cache this
image once it's loaded so that duplicate calls won't issue a reload, but rather
would return the image we've already loaded in memory. To do this, you're going
to implement the concept of a cache. What will happen is, the first request
will go through, and the data will be loaded. When it's loaded, you add it to
the cache using some key value, like its name, so that subsequent requests,
rather than going out to disk, or to the web, will check the cache first, and
return the already loaded asset. What I'd like you to do is to modify the
following code so the asset loader checks the cache before attempting to load
the image. Now there's a couple things to point out here, is that gCachedAssets
is actually a dictionary object, which means that you need to specify a key and
value when accessing and referencing to it. Also take note, that here in the
img.onload callback is where you need to do your heavy lifting to push your
data into this cache object. Good luck.